würde man eine gewisse sachen oder
personen von denen wir eigentlich die
finger lassen sollten von denen es aber
doch nicht fernhalten können für mich
sind das videos von teenagern die in
erziehungs camps geschickt werden ihr
könnt alle die formate endstationen
wildnis und so weiter und so fort ihr
wissen wir dass alles optimal halten
sich daneben und werden unter
fernsehteam begleitungen irgend ein
abgelegenes landtag beklagt der welt
geschickt sollen wir aber ich bin sehr
heutiges video wieder gefunden und ist
es richtig dass die leute es geht darum
dass ihr mich gibt's nach moldawien
geschickt werden und wir schauen wir die
vorstellung von michael reinke
michael ist 19 jahre alt und wohnt bei
ihrer familie in köln
vor zwei jahren hat sie ihren
hauptschulabschluss gemacht seitdem
besteht michelles alltag ausschlafen
fernseh gucken und mit freunden abhängen
okay okay alles da also michelle 19 aus
köln das profil sieht so weit so aus
hauptschulabschluss seit zwei jahren
arbeitslos ich will noch eine sache kurz
vorne weg sein bevor wir unseren spaß
haben leute diese ganzen sachen die in
diesen fernsehern umweht müsst ihr auch
immer mit ein bisschen abstand
betrachten ich habe letztens was richtig
krass war eine nachricht von jenny
bekommen leute kennt ihn auch jenny von
endstation wildnis die von euch schon so
ein halbes jahr bis jahr dabei sind
werden sich daran erinnern habe ich
einige videos darüber gemacht und diese
jenny hat mir eine mail geschrieben und
hat mir von ihrer wirklich krassen nicht
ganz leichten vergangenheit erzählt und
auch davon wie man von so einem
kamerateam personen dreh auch
manipuliert werden kann also wir müssen
uns alles ein bisschen vorsicht genießen
früh aufstehen ist er nicht so ihr ding
[Gelächter]
eher mäßig leute mäßig das könnte so ein
richtiger game changer seien leute
einfach wenn man irgendwas im leben
verpackt hat und einfach will dass man
das ist nicht so krass shepherd wenn man
sagt kurze pause danach mäßig tut mir
leid das ist gerissen mäßig man hat
jetzt also das gleiche gemacht aber
dieses mäßig das klingt dann so als
hätte man mir sowas gemacht was so
ungefähr ähnlich ist
[Gelächter]
also wir sehen wir sehen die schelle
hassel drei leute
der tag beginnt wirklich in aller
herrgottsfrühe leute um 11 geht's los
leute und es man hat nicht mal morgens
irgendwie zeit kurz zu sich zu kommen es
geht direkt los mit duschen freunde
treffen da muss man sich wirklich nicht
wundern wenn man danach erstmal zwei
stunden schlaf braucht es ist ein
krasser hasse leute ist ein krasser hast
du ganz ehrlich wir sollten uns gedanken
darum machen ob das noch lange
durchhaltbar ist für unsere junge
generation nicht nur um 11 uhr aufstehen
sondern auch noch den ganzen tag mit
freunden zu müssen findet findet ihr das
ist ein leben sollte meiner meinung nach
niemanden zugemutet werden läuten aber
ich wollte auf eine sache eine das ganz
am anfang ich werde jetzt hier welche
dieses video anschauen so tun als wäre
alles eins zu eins war aber wir behalten
im hinterkopf dass die leute in diesen
videos auch möglicherweise schlechter
dargestellt werde als sie wirklich sind
okay du mich verlassen besteht ein paar
mal im monat mit ihrer mutter putzen
ansonsten auch was sie nicht viel denn
mit dem arbeitsleben hat die blondine
vor allem ein problem
ich sehe ich da gar kein ich sehe kein
problem mit dem arbeitsleben bei ihr sie
die ist doch durchgehend am hasseler
warum muss jetzt der kommentator schon
wieder hätten wetten der kommentator
keine ahnung wie es ist um 11 uhr
aufzustehen und
und ein bisschen was er mich die meisten
leute nicht bedenken wenn man jeden tag
um 11 uhr aufsteht haben einfach kein
frühstück mehr
diese leute können einfach nicht
frühstücken wir müssen direkt
mittagessen label label kann kann ich
auch nachvollziehen ich habe auch einige
tage wo ich bin kein bock habe irgendwie
früh aufzustehen
auch wenn ich als youtube ein bisschen
chillen lebe ich hier auch mal so macht
auf das werden auch schon wieder einige
die kommentare hätten aber ich bin
einfach mehr leute aber die sache ist
die meisten leute stehen halt morgens
auf und denken sich ja ich hab kein bock
ich will gern noch weiter mit meinem
kissen kuscheln aber da ich muss halt so
sie ist einfach so nein sie macht geld
verdienen sie zwar so gut wie kahn ist
aber für einen gewissen luxus wird die
kölnerin trotzdem nicht 40
zu diesem abschnitt zeige ich euch mal
ein kommentar aus der kommentar sektion
weil ich oft liefern handtaschen keine
ahnung habe marie m legt wert auf luxus
bedeutet bei taff also eine sammlung von
fake handtaschen zu haben da muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen heute das finde ich
persönlich angemessen wenn man wie
gesagt schon den wirklich harten und
brutalen lifestyle lebt jeden tag um 11
aufstehen zu müssen einfach kein
frühstück mehr zu haben der sie weiß
aber nicht was frühstück ist dann kann
man sich im gegenzug als luxus schon ein
paar verkannter schon leisten wo kommt
er nur die kohle her fragt man sich also
kurz erklären fußball auskennen ist das
trikot vom ersten fc köln der verein aus
köln in der stadt wo ich auch wohl nicht
sofort auf den fc in sucre der vater
wenn wir schon mal stabiler ehemann und
jetzt bin ich tatsächlich gespannt wie
man diesen lifestyle aufrecht halten
kann also sie wohnt noch zu hause die ja
wirklich meine eltern würden mich wenn
ich das drei wochen machen würde
also kann aber ich hab meinen
schulabschluss und wird einfach drei
wochen lang gar nichts machen die
wirklich am tag 22 nachdem die drei
wochen vorbei sind würde meine mutter
mit keiner
morgenstern bewaffnet in meinem zimmer
steht mich aus dem bett prügeln einmal
klick macht dazu mal zogen um kommt und
versucht eine bewerbung zu schreiben zu
bearbeiten geht oder versucht zu
arbeiten
michelle fühlt überhaupt nicht ich
schaue mir an ihr gesicht sieht sie
denkt sich so dr
was heißt hier versucht zu arbeiten hast
du hast mal hast du mal die menge an
spielzeug gesehen das ist tatsächlich
mit einer der schwersten sachen als
junge hasserin in deutschland dass man
einfach von den eigenen eltern nicht
verstanden weil die eigenen eltern
arbeiten normal gegen jeden tag zur
arbeit und sie verstehen einfach nicht
den hass der es ist sich mehrmals jeden
tag mit freunden zu treffen und einfach
kein frühstück zu haben dass menschen
sich freiwillig für das projekt
entschieden hat noch hoffnung auf einen
sinneswandel
das ist aber vor das ist folgerichtig
wird weil ich glaube ein problem was
auch so viele jugendliche haben ist dass
sie einfach kein vergleich haben wir
jetzt mal auf ried ob mit euch leute die
kinder wachsen einfach auf kriegen von
ihren eltern ein ich eigentlich immer
alles auch eine frage der erziehung
übrigens also die kinder sind ja nicht
selbst in irgend einem vakuum so
geworden das spiel doch die erziehung
mit rein aber wenn die kinder ist
einfach nicht anders kennen als immer
alles so zu bekommen ist es klar also
die lernen das einfach er ja ich bekomme
hier ist beim leben von afriso warum
soll ich dann arbeiten also ein schock
und kann durchaus auch mal hilfreich
sein sollen hatte ich zum beispiel auch
in meinem studio auf
ich war so ein verwöhnter studenten habe
ich einfach mal so richtig gearbeitet
danach und dann hab ich erst gescheckte
ja okay ich habe es eigentlich schon
ziemlich fucking gut dadurch dass ich
jetzt ein fach studieren kann und meine
ganze zeit aufrichten kann soll das hat
meine perspektive verändert ihre grenzen
das wird die nächsten tagen sehen glaube
ich persönlich nicht wobei ganz ehrlich
sind wir ehrlich in diesen
erziehungscamp muss sie kämpfen sich
wahrscheinlich so um 3 uhr aufstehen
also die leute nach hause nehmen wollen
so gut auf ihn verklagt werden sie
hierzu dahin mit so einer einstellung
sogar egal wie gesagt ich stehe um 11
auf sogleich kam ich im jahr als
verfrüht und die modernen sie
wahrscheinlich so wenn du nicht 83
stunden pro tag auf dem feld hassels
hast du einfach nichts zu essen
wir machen keinen sprung in die video
leute jetzt sind sie in moldawien und es
gibt so ein erstes gemeinsames
abendessen leute gebt euch dass der
rechten seite ist der gastgeber der in
moldawien
der ist ja übel sleep alter kann man
schon richtig sonst vita schüchterner
okay der kopf des opfers bild der zopf
zeigt wiederum so eine andere seite von
ihm nur sehr wilde seite
aber ich finde dass ihre mama der
richter
die 18-jährige tochter katja spricht
englisch unsere vierte haben mithalten
können
sind wir ehrlich also sie die katja
diehl ganz links im bild sind dass es
die die tochter wurde von dem gastgeber
der gastgeber auch an sich mehr junge
einer von der 18 jahre alte tochter wie
alt ist er aber jetzt nicht mal gespannt
auf die englisch geld für michael nicht
nicht little bit nicht auf englisch
ich muss an der schönen kleider machen
leute weil die aufgaben schon turbo lang
ist schreibt mir jetzt und in die
kommentare rein wie eure eltern
reagieren würden wenn ihr einfach von
heute auf morgen alles schmeißen wird
und nur noch schälen und bisher
verschlafen wie meine eltern unter
zuhilfenahme von kriegswaffen reagieren
würden habe ich euch ja schon gesagt
heute täglich ein vorgeschlagenes video
ab abonnieren main kanal ich werde schon
raus muss gut